in this campaign we've also heard and
I'm gonna now direct this at Vice
President Biden I do not believe you are
a racist and I agree with you when you
commit yourself to the importance of
finding common ground but I also believe
and it's personal and I was actually
very it was hurtful to hear you talk
about the reputations of two United
States senators who built their
reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country and
it was not only that but you also worked
with them to oppose busing and you know
there was a little girl in California
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bused to school every day and that
little girl was me so I will tell you
that on this subject
it cannot be an intellectual debate
among Democrats we have to take it
seriously
we have to act swiftly as Attorney
General of California I was very proud
to put in place a requirement that all
my special agents would wear body
cameras and keep those cameras on
[Applause]